luke weaver 27 year old right-hander
results lately have been very
encouraging and alex dickerson is the
left fielder for the giants again
tonight
dickerson wraps this one on the ground
and he's got to base it so he takes a
wide turn and the giants have a base
runner then here comes evan longoria
driven
into left center field and hit well and
it's a one-hopper up against the wall
and dickerson is going to be waved in
and he's going to
and the giants take the lead one nothing
stay hot evan longoria here's belt
belt lines this one down the right field
line and that's going to be a base hit
that'll score longoria and belt will
change places with longoria he's got a
double and it's do nothing on the hill
tonight for the giants will be the
right-handed veteran
trevor cahill with two down nobody on
and here is starling
and he got him and they'll end the
ending here's dubon
fastball lined over the middle base
heading to center field well after
seeing all that breaking stuff
curveballs cutters he got a fastball and
he
just barreled it here's yaz
yasrimski drives one to right and it's
going to get past calhoun and devon can
run
and they're going to wave him in and
yostrimski's got a double it's three
nothing he went upstairs one more time
and this time yastremski hit it in the
gap
peralta hitting right at 300.
now he swings and misses at a change up
strike three here's walker
he's struck him out swinging with a
cutter
just off the outside that's three
consecutive striking
second one down sandoval flying out to
win the first
this one hit on the ground up the middle
and a base hit
longoria is going to come in to score
sandoval
picks up a single in an rbi four-nothing
giants
lopez is on his tenth appearance of the
year to start the fourth stremski has
struck out he's got an rb guy double one
for two he starts the fourth we'll count
on you stremski good slider right there
lopez gets his first strikeout
trevor king hill back out there bottom
of the fourth inning and a shot ripped
up the middle center field by starley
martay on the first pitch
and that's the first diamondbacks hit of
the ball game they trail four nothing
here christian walker now
christian walker drives one deep to left
walker off the top of the wall and gone
christian walker gets the diamondbacks
on the board and they cut the lead in
half a fourth of the year for walker
it's four to two wheels starting to come
off for cahill here i don't know if he
can even throw another pitch he does not
look right out there at all
something clearly is not right
physically with trevor k and it looks
like that's going to be it
forward in the fifth here's wilmer now
off the middle ahmed smothers it they'll
get one and
can't get two
tremendous diving stop by nick ahmed to
at least get that one out here already
came on in relief last inning swaying
and a miss and dubon is out of there
strikeout one out here in the sixth
inning here's mikey stremski who has
struck out twice
junior guerra a fastball and two
splitters
and yastremski strikes out for the third
time tonight oh it's mark team a one-two
pitch swing and the
slider is popped up foul crawford racing
over into
foul territory goes into a slide and
makes the catch over near the seats
the giants had the shift on so there was
nobody at third base crawford had to
race all the way over from short on a
ball not hit very high in the air
and finally
as he was approaching the seats he went
into a slide
and he made the catch
second and third now with two outs and a
2-1 count on crawford now they will put
crawford on
and work to the rookie joey bart
lying to second and there's cattell
marte and the giants leave them low to
two-run lead for the giants as trevor
got takes over one-two pitch
and it's lined out towards second to his
left goes flores into a pop-up slide as
he gets up he fires a throw to first in
time to get walker nice play
wilmer flores for out number one escobar
now
down the line in right and that's a fair
ball in the corner for escobar
ms tremski having some issues eduardo's
headed for third and escobar's got a
triple giants trying to keep a two-run
lead vote waiting trevor gott with the
pitch on the way it is swung on and
missed strike three so trevor gott works
around the triple diamondbacks do not
score nicely done tim is hitting 250.
let's see if that plays itself out here
there's the lead off walk to the world's
fastest human
here's martay who's over three
[Applause]
tapped to crawford
that's one and that's all though good
starly marty against his former teammate
on the ground to crawford
side retired nice job by watson forest
jumps on a fastball he can hit
he does and he hits it high
he hits it deep and he hits it out of
here
flores with his eighth of the year
and the giants have a five to two lead
escobar who tripled his last time
taps this one to solano and this should
do it
and the giants pick up a win on this
road trip